secretary Li welcome back to Bloomberg
Peter it's good to be with you as these
spring meetings of the IMF World Bank
get set to kick off what's your
assessment of the global economic
recovery doesn't feel like people are
popping champagne corks here you know
Peter I think as people look around the
world they look to the United States as
a real engine of growth right now and
pleased that the United States is doing
much better and there's a lot of
attention on how resilient in and how
much the US economy is recovered I look
around the world and there's clearly a
need for more attention to how to
generate a faster more sustainable
growth I think that as you look around
the world there's areas where there's a
need for more use of some of the policy
levers that are available you know we
took advantage of all the policy levers
to get our economy back in gear monetary
policy fiscal policy reforms
particularly in the financial area a lot
of economies that need to use all the
levers that are only using some mr.
secretary let's name some names you've
gone to this before who is it you're
talking about but look we go around the
world and and and there's clearly a
shortage of demand in a number of places
Europe demand has been has been soft
policy could help drive demand you know
the monetary policy tools are being used
the fiscal policy tools and the reforms
that are needed in many parts of the
economy would be very well timed if they
were put in place along with the
monetary tools you go to Asia and in
Japan and China Japan has a policy three
arrows they used monetary policy out of
the box these physical policy out of the
box a little bit of you know kind of
question as to how to balance their
long-term need to get their debt under
control with the need to have fiscal
policy that keeps growth moving in the
short-term the reforms have been a
little slower they need to get those
into place and they need to keep focused
on the fiscal tools as well as the
monitoring tools and you get to China
and China has enormous reforms on its
agenda in terms of what its set forth to
move its economy towards a more
market-oriented
market driven approach moving those
reforms forward opening their their
economy their markets their their
financial system to to market forces is
critically important the sooner they do
that the better before we talk about
some of those other places let me ask
you about the u.s. because the IMF did
downgrade its assessment of growth for
this year for the for the u.s. down half
a percentage point we saw pretty weak
jobs number the other day are we hitting
a week patch right now I think if you
look at the trajectory over the last
year 18 months it is it is showing
consistent trend in the right direction
sustainable strong growth I think if you
look at the where the IMF is now it's
pretty similar to our projection of
where the US economy is and you know a
US economy growing in the range of just
under just above three percent is it
something the world looks at is being a
driver of global economic growth I think
it's a great thing that the US economy
is doing better I don't think it's
sufficient to drive the entire global
economy for the US economy to be the one
area of real strength now obviously
there's there's a bit of it pick up in
economic activity in a bunch of places
that's welcome how durable it is how
structural it is is something that there
has to be a focus on and i think that
the opportunity to move economic growth
in the right direction is very much
related to policies that governments
have control over and that's one of the
reasons is important to have these
discussions at the IMF meetings about
using all the levers that we
policymakers have one big topic you ever
sector you know is going to be the
strength of the dollar and the argument
being made at the IMF knows where is
that the strength of the dollar is one
of the things holding the US economy
back are you okay with it look I think
if you look at the US economy that the
relative strength of the US economy
compared to other economies around the
world explains what the current currency
valuations are it's arently coming from
our strength and relatively speaking
less strong economies elsewhere which is
why I'm focusing on the need for other
economies to be stronger I certainly
don't want the US economy to get weaker
that we have we have the good fortune of
having the stronger economy
the other economies need to get stronger
you know I think you do have to
distinguish between currency valuations
that are a result of differential
economic performances from policies that
are designed to gain unfair advantage we
have you know made very clear that if
there are kinds of policies intervention
that are unfair that are designed to
gain advantage and trade it's
unacceptable we push back very hard on
it and I think we've done so with
considerable success over the last
couple of years what we're seeing now is
the fact that our economy is
outperforming other economies and the
focus has to be on other economies and
other policymakers using the tools to
get their economies moving in a better
direction in a stronger direction your
predecessor Larry Summers has generated
a lot of debate over his argument for
the secular stagnation diagnosis as to
what's happening around the world the
risk of that going forward what do you
fall in this debate look I think that
we've shown in the united states that
when you put good policies in place the
economy response to it there is a need
for Policy look we have a need for more
policy here in the United States there's
no doubt that our economy could do even
better than it's doing if we invested in
infrastructure more if we changed our
immigration laws if we did the things
that if we do reformed our tax code to
have a tax code that was more
encouraging of investment and more
competitive worldwide and closing
loopholes that make it inefficient and
lead to less effective investment
strategies so there are things we can do
I think it's incumbent on policymakers
to move the dial in the direction of
creating more economic growth you know I
think there's many areas around the
world right now where economies could be
doing better if policy we're doing
better let me ask about a couple other
issues likely to come up in the course
of this week in the talks first of all
you've got a meeting with the greek
Finance Minister this week the president
is going to be meeting with them as well
what's the u.s. message to Greece right
now well it'll be the first time I've
actually met with them we've spoken on
the phone but
had the opportunity to meet with them
before my message is going to be the
same as the message that I've delivered
over the phone on quite a number of
occasions it's the grease needs to get
down to the technical work of making a
list of the changes and policies that
it's prepared to put in place so that it
can work with the institutions to come
to a mutual understanding of a path
forward so that they can get out of the
cycle of being in kind of one crisis to
another you know the the there were I
think the rhetoric was not helpful early
on and I sent a signal to both the Greek
government and to the institutions as
they're now called that everyone had to
tamp down the rhetoric and get to the
technical work of seeing what policies
can be put in place to address this
obviously we better if the work had been
done six weeks ago and not over the next
six weeks but there's no time to waste
and the work needs to be done does it
does the US and just to be clear my
understanding is the president's can be
speaking to the the Hellenic celebration
day and they'll be there yeah it's not
it's not a bilateral meeting gotcha does
the u.s. have an economic interest in
making sure Greece stays within the
eurozone is this something in play for
the United States look I think that the
there's no doubt that if this leads to a
crisis that such as Greece leaving the
the euro zone it will cause an enormous
amount of disruption in hardship in
Greece I have said consistently that no
one should think that all of the risk of
a change like that is predictable in
advance and you know even if the
contagion risk is much less now than it
was saying 2012 and earlier it would not
be a good thing in a world economy just
recovering from a deep recession to have
that kind of uncertainty introduced so I
think is in everyone's interest for this
to be worked through but it really means
getting down to that not very exciting
not very rhetorical business of going
through all the details the budget
details that were formed details
schedule and there needs to be a
credible plan forward and obviously
Greek the Greek government has to take
the lead and the institutions have to be
reasonable working with the Greek
government and the faster that work is
done the better a China issue the
creation of this Asian infrastructure
investment bank there's been a lot of
debate over over the u.s. handling of
this and I want to see if I can get your
take on it the initial message from the
United States to friends and allies was
don't join up some of them decided to
join up some saw that is a snub to the
United States what's your take on that
was this miss played and is it raising
any questions about US influence
particular that part of the world well
let me be clear what our message has
been and continues to be from the
beginning we've said it's a good thing
if China wants to invest more in global
infrastructure investment there is a
deep need for global infrastructure
investment China is the second largest
economy one of the two largest economies
in the world China playing a more
significant role there is a positive
thing well we've said to China to other
countries is it's really important as
you launch something like the Asia
infrastructure bank to make sure that
you do it right that you have good
governance in place that you avoid
having problems with either the social
impact environmental impact or economic
impact of the projects I actually was
quite encouraged by the conversations
that I had
I was in Beijing just two weeks ago that
I think the Chinese have heard that
message they are very focused on having
a process in place where their initial
projects meet a high standard we've made
clear to China and to the international
financial institutions that we very much
look forward to being able to
collaborate working together for example
the World Bank in the Asian Development
Bank working with the Asia
infrastructure Bank we've made the offer
to the Chinese we look forward to
working bilaterally to help them avoid
mistakes that they would like to admit
could you see the u.s. signing up look I
think the question is can this get to a
place where it is accomplishing the goal
that we both share of having good
sustainable investment and
infrastructure and that's what we're
working together and we haven't
foreclosed any options for the future
but right now the question is as they
launch the the new Asia infrastructure
bank how do how do they make sure that
it operates in a way that it really
enhances the economic opportunities in
that in the areas where they are
investing and what can we and the
international financial institutions do
to help make sure that that's done in an
effective way and I'm hopeful that we'll
be successful working together with the
end of the story is good investments and
solid projects that advance economic
growth that's a good thing and that's
not and we have never discouraged
participation in that kind of investment
we have said it is important to do it
right and we continue to believe that
and we want to be partners in helping
China and the partners that they have in
the Asia infrastructure bank achieve
that goal really quick the Iran
negotiations among your many
responsibilities here of course Treasury
handles the sanctions component this
you've been briefing lawmakers up on
Capitol Hill I know the White House said
the president's willing to sign this
bipartisan legislation that's emerged
from the Foreign Relations Committee but
it's pretty clear you guys don't love
this legislation is there a risk that
this still could unwind these
negotiations could derail these
negotiations look i think that the
president has made clear many times that
he thinks is important that Congress not
take action that had the effect of
disrupting the negotiations while
still underway and working towards
conclusion I think yesterday the White
House indicated that the president was
prepared to sign the the compromise that
had been developed it addressed the most
significant concerns that the
administration had raised both in terms
of conditions and certifications and the
terms of schedule I think that's an
important set of changes and we look
forward to working with the Congress as
we go back to resume the negotiations
the goal here is to have a good solid
agreement that achieves the result of
making sure that Iran cannot get nuclear
weapons we believe that the framework is
a very important step in the direction
of getting there but we still have work
to do between now and June thirtieth to
complete it and that's the task ahead of
us that we're we're going back to work
on final question mr. secretary it's tax
day in America can you give American
taxpayers any hope any confidence that
there's made progress this year on tax
reform particularly business tax you
know Peter I am continuing to feel that
there is an opportunity for business tax
reform this year that's actually
considerably greater than conventional
wisdom in Washington people have been
downplaying the chances you know it's
not hard to say tax reform is hard tax
reform is always hard it was hard in the
1980s it's hard today it'll be hard when
it comes up in the future taking away
tax breaks loopholes and deductions and
replacing it with a more sensible system
of lower statutory rates and an
international tax system that works is
hard but there's the great advantage to
it the economic benefit is great I mean
right now we have the highest statutory
tax rate in the developed world and it
makes it hard for us companies to
compete around the world that doesn't
have to be we can fix that we saw last
year at this time people were outraged
at inversions we need to fix that by
having a statutory rate that makes sense
in closing the inversion loophole I
think that the linked infrastructure is
key three years ago the president said
we should use the one-time revenue that
comes for
doing international tax reform and we
should take portion of that revenue and
use it to pay for a multi-year
infrastructure program I think there's
considerable interest in that in
Congress and I think that the fact that
our surface transportation bill expires
the fact there's a need for Congress to
deal with a funding source for
infrastructure combined with the fact
that there's considerable overlap in
conceptual approach on business tax
reform between Republicans and the White
House and and and others is a reason to
to be considerably more optimistically
conventional wisdom you know I often
take the risk of defying conventional
wisdom because if you assume that you
can't get anything done then you don't
try and you always have a
self-fulfilling prophecy the only way
that hard things are done is if you
tackle them if you put in the hard work
and if you look up all Ryan is saying
chairman of the Ways and Means Committee
what I'm saying it's there's more
overlap than you normally see between
the two of us that should be a source of
optimism to people who want to get
business tax reform done we'll see what
happens mr. secretary thank you for the
time appreciate it thanks Peter